on peut rester ça vous dérange pas
grand seigneur
qui a été transmis par la dgem vous avez
rempli en tout cas
un document sur lequel vous mentionnez
vous mentionnez les points d'étape en
tout cas à quel stade était déjà
certaines actions donc je considère que
je considère il avait déjà dit
d'ailleurs au mois de juillet dernier il
y a eu un point d'étape sur l'évaluation
des mesures qui étaient prises et au
mois de juillet on reconnaissait déjà
que des actions concrètes avaient déjà
été mises en oeuvre et bon tout n'était
pas encore mis en place donc il y avait
des actions pour la santé même si pour
les sargasmes ça devient récurrent c'est
difficile de faire plus mais il y a des
en fait entre l'État et les EPCI et les
collectivités il y a des des
financements qui ont été mis en place
donc c'est sûr que il y a deux actions
qui sont faites qui ne sont pas qui ne
veut pas l'intégralité des
problématiques parce que tout ce qui est
olfactif enfin tout le reste ça c'est
autre chose et
les collectivités sont confrontées
régulièrement à
cet échouage et il récupère tant bien
que mal et il trouve de plus en plus les
lieux pour faire les pandage mais bon
c'est problème sinon concernant et il
est égalité alors il y a un certain
nombre de documents qui sont en cours de
rédaction d'après ce qui a été transmis
mais en lisant et en observant ce qui se
met en place je trouve que le fait
d'avoir mentionné la pluie des
différents services de l'État et
particulièrement la direction générale
de la sécurité civile gestion des crises
c'est important pour accompagner à la
fois et les différents services les
collectivités mais aussi les autres
partenaires il est à mon avis important
aujourd'hui que les collectivités que
tous les toutes les collectivités du
travail en véritable coordination d'une
part que les documents
d'informations sur les risques majeurs
les dix crimes doivent être mis à jour
elle doit régulièrement ainsi que les PC
les PCs et les PPRM parce qu'on a vu
avec Fiona récemment il est important
qu'il y a une très une très
une réactivité très très rapide de gérer
parce que là on l'a vu
l'expérience des autres
aléas de ce type n'a pas forcément
servi mais je crois que le fait de
d'avoir des documents et d'avoir des
aléas ça permet en tout cas chacun de se
remettre en cause et même les
populations la culture il faut
travailler sur cette culture action
parce que hier des journées japonaises
qui se font il y a un certain nombre de
choses qui se font déjà maintenant il
s'agira de faire
plus davantage et d'impliquer davantage
les populations
il faut qu'elles sont en cours toutes
les étapes de prévention donc le fait
également de pouvoir permettre aux
associations agrées de bénéficier des
bons fonds barniers c'est important
parce que là on l'a vu avec Fiona du
côté de la rivière sens où et il y avait
plusieurs associations qui intervenaient
là donc il y a des associations qui
pourraient peut-être faire des dossiers
pour bénéficier parce que les
associations qui intervenaient là
c'était qui des associations qui
préparaient pour le sauvetage pour le
sauvetage donc c'est des associations
peut-être d'utilités publiques je pense
mais qui prépare des jeunes et qui
forment des gens pour le sauvetage nous
sommes dans des îles ou il y a la mer
tout autour et malheureusement il y a
beaucoup de personnes ne savent pas
nager et pour le sauvetage en mer il a
prévention c'est important donc pour la
question de l'octroi de mer sur les sur
et filament tout ce qui contribuait à
apporter des secours par exemple avec la
Croix-Rouge ou alors
qui venait qui viennent dans nos
territoires et ça je suis le cas par
exemple pour ce matin
les personnes qui viennent pour secourir
et qui amènent aussi quelques fois des
denrées les produits de première
nécessité et bien tout ça il y avait le
droit de mère dessus donc le fait de
continuer à travailler pour qu'il n'y
ait plus le droit de mère à la France
tout ce qu'ils emmène pour eux-mêmes
parce qu'ils viennent avec
je ne sais pas des tentes en fait c'est
un nombre de choses des produits
également pour améliorer la qualité de
la location nécessaire et là il y avait
le droit de merde dessus donc l'offre
assurantiale c'est très important parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui ne
sont pas assurées mais c'est aussi bon
il y a des personnes qui font le choix
entre bien manger et payer l'assurance
mais il y a quand même des personnes qui
sont assurées beaucoup ne sont pas ne
sont pas malheureusement mais là le
problème de l'offre assurantielle et là
je crois qu'il faudrait beaucoup plus
discuter avec les assurances pour qu'il
y ait des offres adaptées au territoire
par rapport aux différents risques
évidemment mais aussi une politique
incitative avec les col pour qu'il y ait
plus de personnes assurées ça c'est un
parce que c'est à la fois les fonds qui
sont dédiés pour le moment c'est à dire
les personnages
donc il y a quand même des possibilités
il y a des fonds de secours mais avec le
réchauffement climatique nous aurons de
plus en plus d'aller à donc de plus en
plus de personnes qui pourront que ce
soit sur nos territoires
ultra marin mais aussi dans l'Hexagone
on le voit qui devront bénéficier sur
ces fonds qui sont des des fonds de
solidarité donc si on a un site pas plus
de personnes aussi à à ce à apprendre
des assurances et si on incite pas les
assurances à mettre aussi des
possibilités pour que les personnes
aient les moyens de le faire donc on
sera dans une situation où les fonds
secours avec l'État vont en fait un
moment donné ce serait difficile parce
que la fréquence des aléas on le voit ça
se répétitif pour les plans communaux de
sauvegarde et les PPRL il est impératif
et là c'est dans l'urgence je pense que
tu es régulièrement parce que il y a des
personnes qui changent
des référents notamment des changes qui
changent de service mais qui sont aussi
de coordonnées
il faut que ce sera régulièrement révisé
et dans alors j'ai vu que ça avance
quand même très bien et les fonds
Barnier l'usage les font Barnier qui a
été simplifiée
simplifié parce que beaucoup de
collectivités les vrais ne pouvaient pas
avoir les fonds propres pour avoir les
10% donc avec la FD il y a des
possibilités et les possibilités
également de mobilisation du feu c'est
bien c'est d'actualité en ce moment
Guadeloupe avec ce qui est préconisé à
la fois par le ministre lors de son
passage mais aussi les différents les
autres services de l'État alors ce qu'il
faut maintenant c'est mieux travailler
les plans les plans de continuité
d'activité et à tous les niveaux et
son impératif selon moi dans la mesure
où maintenant on ne doit plus négliger
le côté économique et d'un côté
social et sécurité par rapport aux
problèmes environnementaux on l'a vu
chez nous il y a des ponts par exemple
des ponts qui sont plus récents
d'ailleurs que certains qui sont là
depuis plus de 100 ans et bien des ponts
qui se sont effondrés et ça gêne la
circulation par exemple dans les bananes
pour permettre aux entreprises de faire
la cueillette des bananes et de les
emmener dans les lieux de
conditionnement pour après les vendre
c'est aussi pour les
exploitations agricoles mais aussi pour
les éleveurs entre autres donc ça gêne
un peu la circulation et des biens et
c'est une entreprise sont handicapées
par cela donc on doit davantage
travailler sur cette coordination entre
le côté économique le côté social que je
viens de dire et aussi
le PCI alors dans les différents plans
lorsque nous avons fait le rapport il y
a des EPCI qui avaient été invités à la
préfecture vers notre demande pour
parler de la coordination et des
documents de document de prise en compte
des aléas et pour les plans c'est que
notamment et bien il y a seulement deux
EPCI qui étaient représentés une
présidente elle qui était venue
elle-même et une technicienne directrice
d'un service environnement et qui ne
comprenait pas pour qu'on leur avait
demandé de venir si bien que les autres
n'étaient pas là et on a compris que les
deux qui sont il y a une la présidente
c'était madame caramel à l'époque et a
dit moi on m'a convoqué bon je viens je
dis je viens mais je vois pas ce que
j'ai avoir et bien oui on nous avons
transféré nous avons transféré sur des
EPCI sur des EPCI mais aussi sur les
syndicats mixtes c'est un nombre en tout
cas de légataire notamment par exemple
pour l'eau et l'assainissement on est en
plein dedans parce qu'il y avait déjà
des problèmes d'eau mais finalement les
amplifié donc il y a des séances de
compétences qui ne sont pas forcément
dans les documents locaux dans les
communes quelquefois il se limitent à
ceux qui concerne la commune or pour les
déchets pour les déchets c'est
transférer pour l'eau et
l'assainissement s'est transféré pour
l'électricité aussi c'est transférées
donc il y a il faut que dans les
documents il y ait également tous ces
tous ces partenaires avec les différents
services de l'État il a ça n'apparaît
pas dans les documents donc il est
urgent que qu'il y ait une véritable
communication avec les territoires et
les EPCI en 30 mais les communes aussi
pour qu'il y ait donc ce plan de
continuité d'activité non pas seulement
au niveau local mais que ça prenne en
compte ces différents partenaires parce
que
à certains moments pour le débliment et
de chaque va dire en nombre c'est pas
moi c'est le c'est le PCI mais le PCI
est en fait il n'y a pas encore le lien
il y a le lien pour quand tout
fonctionne normalement comme on vient de
parler
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne pas mais il
y a le lien dans les documents de
sécurité il est impératif d'aller mettre
alors il y a également
alors j'ai parlé des finances donc les
documents et les relations des réunions
de coordination fréquentes et des
simulations à faire de plus en plus
parce que à certains moments pas répondu
dans une période ces jours-ci là il y a
pas mal d'actions qui sont faites là
j'ai vu pour la Guadeloupe j'ai vu pour
la Martinique monsieur quelque chose
avec sur son territoire à partir du 20
en fait il y a un certain nombre
d'actions mais hormis le fait qu'il
faille faire évidemment ce genre de de
d'action pour sensibiliser les uns les
autres mais il faut au niveau de la
proximité parce que j'ai vu un goyave à
Capesterre de l'eau à Bailly
habitants dans certaines localités donc
maintenant il y a le travail que les
mères mais aussi les gpci doit faire un
renfort et de façon coordonnée dans les
territoires en fonction des risques de
proximité parce à l'échelle de la
commune il y a les pluies il y a un
certain nombre de dispositions qui sont
faites les gens connaissent telles
hommes mais il y a des personnes qui
habitent dans les endroits et qui
n'avaient jamais pensé qu'ils auraient
eu qu'il serait confrontés à certains
risques donc là c'est le travail de
proximité qu'il faut intensifier et la
prise en compte des psychotromains par
exemple après il maria on a vu que à
Saint-Martin bon c'était au niveau de
l'organisation il a continué tous les
activités par rapport à
saint-martin-demi c'était deux choses
différentes c'est maternité a pu avec
son constitué d'activité réagir très
vite et la Transat à Jésus et la
mondiale qui est arrivé et arrivé sans
qu'il y a aucun souci à ce matin jusqu'à
maintenant il y a encore des blessures
et il y a aussi l'organisation en termes
de santé et de prise en charge
psychologique alors dans le rapport on
parle des psychotromas et à mon avis il
est important aujourd'hui que l'on
puisse
organiser et mettre en oeuvre et là les
centres un centre régional le
psychotroproba cette possibilité parce
qu'il y a déjà des psychologues en fait
il y a des associations il y a ici il y
a des trucs mais organisé pour que
chaque fois que le préfet en fonction
des alertes du niveau d'alerte pour que
ces personnes-là soient déjà mobilisées
faut pas qu'on attende longtemps pour
chercher pour pointer il y a déjà avec
l'ARS avec l'association en fait des
ponts qui sont possibles donc non pas à
créer quelque chose
qui ne pourrait pas servir mais
organiser mettre en place une déjà une
coordination pour que de la même façon
quand on au niveau du COD il y a des
dispositions qui sont prises et que ces
personnes-là soient déjà plus ou moins
en alerte également et mobiliser et en
fonction de de l'aller à et des
conséquences éventuelles et bien ces
personnes seraient déjà clairement
identifiées donc je crois que ça c'est
important et on l'a vu
et lorsqu'il y a eu là il y avait des
personnes à prendre en charge
psychologiquement qui était assez Martin
donc c'est compliqué à ce matin parce
que psychologue le plus proche était il
fallait aller à saint-martin-le-my donc
la personne va une fois deux fois mais
après comme il faut prendre l'avion il y
a pas les moyens et tout donc c'est
compliqué alors que si il y a au
préalable un centre régional psychotroma
donc cette organisation se met en place
avec les personnes qui sont sur le
différent territoires et de façon
coordonnées s'il faut mobiliser
quelqu'un qui peut aller qui en fait là
c'est quelque chose qui est déjà prévu
avec vraiment
référentiel en fait quelque chose de
bien une méthodologie on organisation
qui serait faite par anticipation donc à
ce stade
je la je ne lui a fait je m'arrête à
cela et en tout cas je remercie
vos équipes pour le travail qui a été
fait pour le tableau qui nous a été
remis pour nous dire que ça c'était mais
j'ai constaté également sur un terrain
parce que j'ai participé à une réunion
qui a eu à Capesterre et où j'ai évoqué
enfin certaines possibilités qu'on avait
et
j'ai vu également des réponses qui ont
été données après à Vieux Habitants
parce qu'il y a une deuxième réunion en
présence du ministre et des maires et je
crois que là les choses se coordonnent
davantage
par contre et et là c'est la question de
l'eau qui est un problème récurrent mais
dans cette situation là il faut à ce
moment-là qu'on essaie qui est le
meilleur coordination donc là ça a
permis
qu'il y ait entre deux communes voisines
et limitrophes qu'il y ait un dialogue
et c'est pour cela qu'on dit que si on a
un mot que les choses doivent se faire
la présence du ministre délégué à
facilité a été facilité facilitateur
avec le préfet mais il y a déjà des
problèmes récurrents entre les les EPCI
et c'est tout ce qui pour lesquels en ce
moment il y a des dégâts mais il faut au
préalable dans cette situation là et
pour éviter le pied parce que il y a des
risques d'incendie et le problème qui se
pose c'est que là on est sur des risques
de certains hommes d'alliés on ne pense
pas au risque d'incendie mais c'est un
vrai sujet parce que les pompiers sont
alertés et j'ai donné un document à
Monsieur le Ministre délégué le 30 je
crois parce que le 10
et souvent sollicité mais quand il y a
pas d'eau à certains endroits c'est
difficile c'est très difficile donc ils
ont ils utilisent les moyens qui ne
devraient pas pour certains endroits
mais ils ont des moyens
pas suffisant et d'autres moyens pour
avoir une meilleure capacité de pouvoir
éteindre les incendies parce que on n'a
pas eu tout ce qu'on a eu en Gironde et
dans d'autres par exemple
merci mais pour les incendies qui
pourraient maîtriser facilement et bien
on a vu un moule une pharmacie sur deux
étages se brûlés et ça c'est pas dans
les risques naturels mais c'est avoir
parce que c'est une des conséquences des
problèmes hématiques liés à l'eau voilà
ce que je peux dire à ce stade monsieur
le Président et merci beaucoup et je
remercie d'être resté
oui merci merci victoire merci
effectivement d'être resté monsieur
monsieur le fancy
dans la mesure où on avait auditionné
les services de l'État en juillet et
donc c'est la première fois je crois
qu'on réalise cet exercice de suivi sous
cette forme et on l'a eu quand même un
gros travail de réponse donc merci à vos
services d'avoir pris la peine vraiment
de d'apporter des réponses les plus
précises possible quand elles étaient
possibles
sur une centaine de propositions il y a
80% des propositions qui ont reçu soit
en début de réponse soit des écarts et
le reste certaines ne sont pas forcément
pertinentes aux relève d'autres
ministères d'ailleurs ce que vous
relevez dans le tableau de suivi
toujours est-il qu'on peut quand même
considérer avec le cadre d'intervention
générale et tu l'as rappelé victoire
c'est quand même amélioré de notre point
de vue moi j'ai un seul regret je ne
l'avais pas dit à l'Élysée le 7 le 7
septembre quand le président c'était
avait pensé évidemment aux victimes des
événements climatiques c'est quand nous
avait quand même annoncé une loi sur la
prévention des risques naturels majeurs
et que ça s'est transformé en sait
comment ça s'est terminé
[Musique]